la tempête a lié aux marée haute a
provoqué d'importantes inondations
certains villages sinistrés sont coupés
du monde plus d'eau ni d'électricité et
les routes impraticables reportage à
loix en ré antoine gaveau bernard bonne
arme
aujourd'hui les pompiers sont les seuls
à pouvoir emprunter cette route ou ce
qu'il en reste
sur l'île de ré la tempête a fait lâcher
de digues
la mère a envahi la terre et couper
certains habitants du reste du monde
alors voyez une voiture alors que beauté
dont ont peuplé de l'arrière elles sont
montées dans plusieurs vagues géantes
cette nuit et une partie du petit
village de loi est englouti au moi j'ai
jamais vu ça de toute façon même mon
père kaka 81 7 ans donc il a dit que non
ils avaient vu venir
un peu plus loin mais jamais jusqu'ici
dégâts matériels et catastrophe
économique pour les éleveurs d'huitres
nombreux sur l'île j'ai pu cabanes
ostréicoles tout le matériel est sous
l'eau est bon mais pas qu'on n'a pas pu
aller voir baisser taupe est beau et bon
bah voilà voulait plus travailler la
nuit là je crois que je vais arrêter
complètement parce que c'est le moral
n'y est plus du tout là et l'électricité
est ce qu'on sait plus d'électricité
plus d'eau non plus les habitants
attendent la décrue et s'organise avec
les moyens du bord
débrouille comme on peut en avoir a pas
d'électricité on a eu des réserves mais
nos congélateurs forcément ils vont on
va aviser pour faire à manger pour pour
se chauffer et puis voilà sur l'île de
ré on annonce à nouveau des marais
importance pour les prochains jours
cet isolement pourrait donc durer toute
la semaine